[Music]
did you bleed on the carrots well i died
yep probably
happy christmas just did alive yes i
think so
jesus they're early
tony and simon robbed the petrol station
oh what fun
we make tremendous criminals that felt
so good
we're all getting old we were getting
old
[Music]
it's just one potato each just one for
everyone
should anyone watch the queen's speech
well she's clearly in some bunkers set
up you know filled with tins of baked
beans and dog food
[Music]
here's to the lives that we've shared
to our beautiful children
our beautiful friend
may we rest in peace
[Applause]
i just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive
[Music]
we should have all voted green
[Music]
[Applause]
we just want to make sure that you
understand that as your parents
we are not to blame
clearly it's not your fault either
[Music]
[Music]
living like that
[Music]
you